schreibt meine kommentare was haltet ihr
davon wenn ich mein hund hole und ich
nenne den browser und ich gehe dann
immer so am wochenende wenn dann der
folge kommt gehe ich dann immer mit dem
hund so ein bisschen spazieren und
schaue mir dann so ein bisschen so die
häuser und so was die anderen so gebaut
haben und schreibt mir dass man einfach
in die kommentare schreibt mauer vor die
coole idee mit dem hund oder schreibt
mauer vor kein bock auf qualitative hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
folge von minecraft hero projekt und
zwar spiele ich heute mal ausnahmsweise
alleine seit den ersten beiden folgen
also ist jetzt nichts ganz besonderes
ich würde sagen wir konnten hier direkt
auf buback ich hoffe der server wird
gestartet ja das ist typischer fehler
immer am anfang
ich bin in den letzten folgen gestorben
weil zur ohne meinen grabstein ihnen die
zerstörte ich hoffe ich sporne nicht bei
den teleporter sonst hab ich eine lange
reise vor mir ich solle mir den
teleporter vor scheiße scheiße alter
[ __ ] wie mache ich das jetzt jetzt muss
ich ja irgendwie was ist das da oben
eigentlich was ist das hier
justus ist nicht auswerten portal aber
da will ich irgendwie ungern rein
tatsache ist diene ich muss jetzt
irgendwie zurück beziehungsweise auf den
weg muss ich mir ein paar sachen finden
also alle meine sachen sind mehr oder
weniger weg und ich musste jetzt
irgendwie dahin finden hast du scheiße
oder machen wir jetzt eine kleine
entdeckungstour einfach ich muss als
5000 blöcke laufen
das wird eine menge ich weiß nicht ob
ich das ich wollte mal ein bisschen
länger aufnehmen so 20 minuten heute
weil die erst mal in folge waren ja 14
minuten und zehn minuten oder so da darf
jetzt mal 15 minuten dranhängen wenn wir
gesagt soll man so 10 bis 20 minuten
ich schaue jetzt mal ganz kurz nach die
waren der normandie todes koordinaten
bei mir
ich hoffe ich werde jetzt nicht
irgendwie von einem mob angegriffen oder
sowas
schauen wir mal ganz kurz nach main
kanal so also ist alles ein bisschen
verdächtig oft schon wieder falsch
geparkte der onyx rollt mich hieß das
sorry dass das ganze ein bisschen aber
ich darf jetzt auch noch mehr auch nicht
pausieren
sowohl mich denn gestorben wird da sieht
man koordinaten so machen die grafiken
bisschen besser so ich trage mir die am
besten jammer hier einfach ein dass die
koordinaten sind nämlich jetzt habe ich
noch von so eine scheiße
die koordinaten sind - 4249 das anderes
die höhe und und 1573 dort da muss jetzt
hinlaufen megageil okay zwei minuten
damit verbracht in welche richtung
wissen dass ach du scheiße jetzt ist ja
auch noch so ein ok in welche richtung
ist das da muss ich auch erstmal wieder
ins minus gehen
das heißt dahin auf jeden fall und das
ist 1500 da muss ich dann auf jeden fall
dahin
das ist das hier oder sondern der
sinnvoll wäre natürlich wenn ich mir
zuerst einmal ist hier irgendwie weiß
ich nicht aber wenn es doch jetzt
theoretisch des smart protection wenn es
doch hier theoretisch night heißt es
doch dann theoretisch gesehen
ach das ist immer noch da kann ich
einfach nur fallen lassen das ist in den
anderen regionen scheint man bett
gemacht er hätte ich mal schafe gefunden
heißt es der theoretisch das ist in
anderen regionen wo eltern diese ganzen
mopste wenn ich die schon sehen
jetzt hat das jahrhundert des todes
lasst mich irgendwie vorbei das heißt ja
das ist in anderen regionen jetzt
eigentlich nur eine blume mittlerweile
angst vor allem ich werde überleben hier
heißt es ja eigentlich dass ich mal ein
bisschen lauter heißt es eigentlich dass
es in den anderen regionen überall
regnen sollte das teils zu mops tonnen
am tag warum habe ich eigentlich immer
dieses immense glück dass die mobs bei
mir alle am transport soll das egal
jetzt könnte ich auf jeden fall mal ein
bisschen quatschen allgemeine wir die
ersten beiden folgen die erste folge kam
nicht so gut an weil ich direkt
gestorben bin das war aber bei allen
kandidaten hat so die irgendwie
gestorben sind nur den baumberger
verstehen wir befinden uns hier auf link
nun ich habe angst vor allen sachen die
ich nicht kenne in diesem projekt
deswegen bin ich da im moment auf euch
angewiesen
ich habe allerdings bisher ja ja ich
habe die karte reden gehört
ich habe allerdings bisher richtig
richtig wenig hilfe so an sich gewesen
dass da ich will da am liebsten gar
nicht rein ich will da gar nicht
reingucken
weil diese ganze todesstrafe wenn ich
einmal sterbe ist halt direkt wirklich
aufnahmestopp ihr wisst bescheid wie es
läuft hier mitbekommen dass ich jetzt
gestern habe auch kein video von hero of
the box als ich dachte schon ich fange
jetzt irgendwo rein
gestern habe ich auch kein video von
hero einfach wegen diesen stopps das
macht das ganze an sich ein bisschen
spannender die todes regel ich werde
auch ergibt mal schreibt es meine
kommentare wenn ich mal ein video machen
soll wo ich euch die todes regel so ganz
genau demonstriere weil kilian von koch
media hat da eine grafik für entwickelt
das ist das eigentlich egal abfälle
diese green das sah so aus wie karotten
ich dachte ich kann das essen ist
sondern dass hier ab schillig das ja ein
cooler wald und das auch kohle das eisen
leute hier lassen uns doch erstmal ein
bisschen runter
jetzt machen wir sollen die sonder
entdeckung so mehr oder
doch auch cool also ich finde das macht
so spaß so dass alles so rauszufinden
deswegen mag ich auch ex sind eigentlich
weil man hier halt nicht so wie in the
beast so richtig des todes viel kraft
bringt sorry dass ich so oft des todes
sage sondern hier geht's halt wirklich
wäre darum dass man ja entdeckt halt
mehr oder weniger und darauf habe ich
halt bot
ich nehme hier die kürbisse einfach mit
ich weiß nicht wofür ich die nase
gebrochen oder kürbisse alle die
minecraft guckt man mir wissen dass
kürbisse seltener sind als diamanten
durchschnittlich ein bisschen ans für
den schießbefehl anja was muss so
bereich brauche
jetzt noch das 1 2 als 31 31 ich hab
hier noch ein glaube ich um mir die
ganzen alterns herstellen zu können die
verbraucher so erstmal hier ein schwert
das haben wir auch leute geschrieben
dass ich mir doch gleich einfach direkt
sein schwert macht zumba schwert dank an
alle das geschrieben habe mich auf jeden
fall wert von euch wegen tipps und freut
mich sehr dass mir so ein paar tipps
gegeben wurden eine menge war es jetzt
nicht dass angekommen ist es wird nur
gesagt deswegen die somit den besten
anfang start erwischt haben weil wir
irgendwie so geile sachen bonds stehen
haben
mit barbara geiger nicht dazu schmelter
oder so was ich weiß nicht was einst
welt heißt kann ich glaube ich auf die
gebiete kann man somit schmelzen hält
einfach smelter auf deutsch übersetzt
was ist genau der vorteil an tims eltern
die sich der aus ich weiß nicht also
könnt ihr wirklich des todes viele tipps
in die kommentare schreiben ich werde
euch dafür nicht irgendwie köpfen oder
so wenn ihr da irgendwas rein schreibt
ganz im gegenteil ich bin da sehr sehr
froh darüber wenn ihr das tut und es
wird gerade nacht es wird nacht freunde
es kann nicht wahr sein es wird nach ich
spiele und es wird eiskalt nach
das kann echt nicht wahr sein was soll
ich denn jetzt machen wenn nachts wird
ich versuche mir dass kohle zu holen
dann kann ich mir halt fackeln machen
und mehr mehr nicht mehr kann ich nicht
machen lassen fährt die angst vor
pferden den ach so ich habe jetzt das
pferdchen da das auch kohle aber es ist
egal ob du schon hauschild ich weiß zwar
nicht ob die mich da so ganz doll mögen
sie sofort kohle was kann abgebaut habe
sodann hause ich da erst mal unter ich
hoffe die haben wolle oder sowas brauch
ich schwöre euch wenn ich eine woche
haben die bringen die besitzer des
hauses um
naja freunde wie gesagt ich nehme allein
auf weil ich bisschen was erzählen
wollte ich habe nämlich heute ein paar
unis das heißt bei einer uni und habe
damals am hospital mitgemacht hospiztag
ist wenn man sich da eben wollte der
mann wissen was ich studieren möchte ich
möchte
ja das sage ich euch wenn es soweit ist
oder soll ich dafür braucht ich weiß
nicht können ja mal schreiben aber das
wissen wollte jedenfalls die gegend ist
hammer geil wenn wir hier im dorf hätte
das wäre des todes geil das direkten
zombie der zudem will ich gar nicht aber
der kommt freundlich zu mir du blöder
pizza da wie komme ich denn das haben
rein was mache ich denn dann in dem haus
habe ich könnt ihr erst mal ein bisschen
kräften kommen du bleibst hier stehen
hallo sehen die manege ist frei okay ich
habe sogar schon eine fackel so wir
haben sogar schon ein kleines gärtchen
hier mit einem tollen baum drin da
scheint fährt schon was vor dem pferd
dann scheiße ich würde das gern boxen
aber guck mal wie die elegantes läuft
hey guck mal wie hier hinten kleiner
hase ich möchte ich auf meinen kopf
nehmen
ich glaube ich kann auch den rechtsweg
machen was da oben auch das in karotten
nähe dieses we will grace solltest mal
boxen rechts x box und kommt
ich hoffe es kommt nicht rüber scheiße
ist das publikum kommt sich die tür oder
wie wird es nicht kommen
aber das sollte man hinkommt ich will
das boxen
das gibt bestimmt des todes viel
erfahrung ich habe ehrlich gesagt angst
dass es irgendwie schafft durch die tür
zu kommen
also wenn ihr gleich sondern so ein
pferd durch die tür kommt na ja luca was
war denn jetzt mit dem ding mit bayer
universität 8 mb am ort ist ja darin
stimmt stellt sich alles von selber und
ich brauche hier links nach dem anderen
ab kommt jetzt mal hierhin kommen
hierher hersteller kleiner mann beenden
nein
die kriegt den lockenkopf drauf ich bin
zu weit weg dieses gras da will ich noch
mitnehmen das kann nämlich leuchten und
damit direkt schon seine post touren
wo also heck sind wird so heftig wie gut
ich hab ein bisschen mann ist alter von
diesem pferd ne warum muss ich das denn
auch boxen
darum bin ich auch so blöd und box das
einfach
na gut wenn wir kraft erst mal ein
bisschen und zwar manchmal ein paar
jungs sogar ohne machen wir ein
perfekter schon manchmal 24 das sport
der sportbund dann kann man sich ja
theoretisch mal runter bauen ich weiß ja
nicht wie lange es noch dauert bis
wieder tag wird ich war nicht an einer
universität und an dieser universität
habe ich einfach speech hat mitgemacht
ein hospiz tag ist ein tag wo man sieht
wie das alles da so abläuft in einer
universität
wieso also ich hab einen tag ausgewählt
bekommen der halt besonders gut geeignet
für die sachen die ich mir vorgestellt
habe also was gab es da ich sage euch
nicht die genaue richtung aber ich sage
euch nicht ich auch nicht wo ich war ich
war entweder in berlin hamburg münchen
köln
dresden frankfurt oder oder was war noch
mal das andere was andere standorte und
andere stuttgart in einem von diesen
städten war ich könnte ja mal raten was
ihr denkt oh ja ich weiß nicht ob es
raus finden werdet aber schon egal
ein bisschen wild zu schweren stürzen
mussten dann ist eine höhle
ich finde einfach eine höhle unter weil
der unter dem haus von diesem von diesen
behinderten typen hier der hier wohnt
papier wieder heiß gewohnt aber
hammergeil alter da ist direkten
spinnenweben teil
[Musik]
natürlich ich habe mir das mal ein
bisschen frei
ich sehe da auch gar nix irgendwie ich
sehe da nur so jahn und so was hängen
eine fackel hin wo ich fühle mich gerade
so wie damals als ich geguckt hat dass
man so richtig weil hexen spiele im
vollbild dass man so richtig dabei ist
und das ist doch hier so dunkel und so
alles ich habe aber wirklich gerade so
ein bisschen angst hier dass ich
irgendwie sterbe deswegen war ich mich
hier kennt mich ja eigentlich luca geht
in die höhle walter
was ist das fast so schlimm der sofort
herunter hing oha
[Musik]
hahahahaha rohstoffe an mass des cross
des cross es fehlen nur noch diamanten
gut auch sehr sehr klug weil man beim
ein crafting table befindet sich gerade
oben
ich baue mir das thema so ein bisschen
zu damit ich mich erinnere in die
wundervolle oder so genau so wie hier so
ja dass das ist halt so ein hospiz tag
ist man als ein paar sachen gezeigt
bekommt die so billig sind für einen
selbst ich brauche jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal offen wo ich war das pferdchen
schon wieder stoppt das mag nicht ab da
draußen steht das komme ich gebe jetzt
noch eine chance wenn du die box werden
will dann kommt ihr an
doch jetzt läuft es wieder weg feigling
kommt ja ja ja ja kontakt kommen
hier kommt keiner man ja los kommt dann
kommt zu dir du gehört man komplette
konzert auftreten sollte
hammergeil ist hat aufgehört ich glaube
das hat einfach so ihre das hat einfach
so seine spur der so immer nach läuft
man hätte ich möchte ich doch nur box to
doch nie so dann bräuchten jetzt erst
mal ein paar schöne rohstoffen hier ab
als wenn ich mich jetzt schon brett
sondern sondern zum kakao oder wozu luca
allgemein redstone braucht ja redstone
experte schlechthin das darf mir
natürlich nie vergessen
satz zusammen man hier allerdings
bekommt man da auf jeden fall erfahrung
aus und ist ja schon mal ganz gut da
unten sehe ich schon diamanten also
diamanten sind nichts besonderes in exit
er braucht jetzt nicht irgendwie denkt
die jungs der lukas schon diamanten
davon waren screenshot weil ich der bin
ich habe einfach diamanten gefunden
chillig nein ich fast jeden tag so ja
toll
das sind sogar richtig viele was mache
ich mir dann daraus macht mir daraus
machen wir daraus also diamanten sind
echt nichts besonderes in excel oder so
aber es hat trotzdem cool also die sind
nichts besonderes weil die kommen oft so
häufig vor weil es halt so immens
heftigem ops gibt so an alle die jetzt
noch dran sind wegen dem studium und
wada halt und das war halt richtige
man's mühselig sich dadurch den alltag
zu boxen weil ich kannte da halte ich
gar kein ich saß da dann so alleine rum
in dem kurs und ich hab ich halt mit den
angefahrenen weil ich bin jetzt ein tief
der geht auch leute zu und kann mit
denen in kontakt treten und dann halt
nicht so rum und sagt gar nichts
es war halt bestand aus marketing und so
ein paar anderen faktoren noch und er
ich muss halt gucken was da rauskommt
ich war jedenfalls den ganzen tag weg
und deswegen kamen eventuell vorgestern
ein paar probleme mit dem upload
ich habe vorgestern habe ich so mein
setup hochladen und die boppard 2 und so
was alles und sonst da falsch deswegen
das kann eigentlich alles zeitnah ich
glaube da musste ich nichts
nachdem nachhinein noch mal korrigieren
da ich denke gar nicht mitbekommen dass
nicht dabei ich bin halt um 5 uhr 55
aufgestanden war sehr heftig musste ich
auch weil ich ja sehr weit weg musste
und ja
gut das war halt so mein tag was das
denn dann kriegt man einfach ist es
einfach ein knochen erz man kriegt man
kriegt einfach die sachen die man kriegt
wenn man who was wollt ihr von mir
der stopp donnern ein kopf drum übrigens
hatte ich mir gedacht dass ich mit hund
hole in diesem exit links kassiererin
den ich benenne ich hab voll bock ihren
hund zu holen die nicht pause und dann
schreibt man eine kommentare was haltet
ihr davon wenn ich mein hund hole und
ich nenne den browser und ich gehe dann
immer so am wochenende wenn dann eine
folge kommt gehe ich dann immer mit dem
hund so ein bisschen spazieren und
schaue mir dann so ein bisschen so die
häuser und so was die anderen so gebaut
haben und schreibt mir dass man einfach
in die kommentare schreibt mauer auf all
die coole idee mit dem hund oder
schreibt mauer vor kein bock auf gefolgt
von die charaktere und dann wenn ich mal
schauen ob ich das dann mache oder nicht
weil ich habe auf jeden fall bock drauf
so hund sondern immer so ein bisschen
chillen und so wünsche ich halt ihr
wisst bescheid wisst ja dass ich sowas
mag habe machen die wir machen die wir
die anderen nicht machen vielleicht sind
wir nicht die besten den technik etc
aber vielleicht sind wir so die
liebevollen so ich hab ja bei facebook
ein bild gepostet beschreibung der
städte statt gelb des todes unproduktiv
am anfang aber danach produktiv statt
rot einfach die produktivsten von beginn
an unter statt blau da wo wir sind liegt
einfach immer besoffen in der ecke rum
ist halt einfach so wird auch so sein
denke ich deswegen bei uns werdet ihr
mir so lachen können bei den anderen
werdet ihr weiß ich nicht sterben
verlangen nein bei den anderen wird
natürlich auch witzig sein und bei den
anderen könnt ihr natürlich auch alle
vorbeigucken weil die wohnen natürlich
auch in anderen regionen und da ist
natürlich auch witzig mal zu sehen wie
das bei den abläuft also sterben vor
langeweile werdet ihr nicht hier wäre da
höchstens ohnmächtig rennspaß natürlich
alles nur spaß hier
ich weiß gar nicht wie viel soll ich
mich jetzt noch mitnehmen welche sind
rohstoffe über rohstoffe hier ist nicht
so einem bock jetzt herzlich so eine
bandbreite an rohstoffen wie
beispielsweise bei dingsbums bei
feedback ist allerdings sehr sehr viel
von den jeweiligen grundbedürfnissen von
den grund rohstoffen sag jetzt mal dass
ich sehe hier zum beispiel eisen
dann sind hier ganz viel platz wie
diamanten haben wir auch schon gefunden
gold ich weiß ja nicht ob gold und so
was alles auch hier seinen hohen
stellenwert haben wie ein biest da bin
ich halt wirklich stark auf eure stark
auf eure hilfe angewiesen
das sehen wir da wirklich auch hilft bei
solchen sachverhalten ich werde jetzt
auch gar nicht viel weiter in der höhle
umgehen
ich würde auch sagen dass ich die zeit
schon wieder dem ende zuneigten oder
weniger wir können echt froh sein dass
die kleine mops sind eigentlich weil wir
endlich auf hardcore spielen setzt man
ernsthaft diesen wirklich nahezu gar
keine mops
ich traue ich auch nicht jetzt noch
weiter rumzulaufen willst und nicht das
eisen da noch mitnehmen und alles obwohl
doch da kommt das alte nehme ich mir
noch mit
ich habe hier echt angst weil das ist
mir irgendwie zu ruhig ich höre nämlich
nix ich höre nur wasser ich habe so
angst dass von hinten gleichen pieper
kommen da hab ich echt kraftvoll angst
irgendwie und wenngleich ein körper
kommen sollte und ich sollte sterben
dann werde ich so meine tastatur gegen
meinen kopf hauen wie ich es noch nie
getan habe aber es kommt keiner so gut
die fackel nehme ich jetzt mit 80 wir
sind wieder bei 19 halb minuten habe ich
jetzt ein bisschen überzogen
gebt mal einen daumen hoch wenn ihr
wollt dass ich die nächste folge auch
noch so alleine machen hier so ein
bisschen ein bisschen ruhiger jetzt
umlauf und dass wir dann halt danach die
folge dann wieder ein bisschen action
geladen damit weil sie nicht könnt ihr
mal rein schreiben ein wenig mehr
aufnehmen soll und dann bin ich vorn ich
bin nicht voll würde ich sagen ich gehe
eben nach oben wenn es euch halt
gefallen hat dürft ihr gerne ein
bisschen nach oben geben wir die fackeln
etwa alle mit und macht das dann hier
und einfach zu weil die fans im garten
riecht ein bisschen wichtiger und gebt
mal daumen hoch wenn ich hier weiter
spielen soll beziehungsweise ich glaube
ich mache es einfach ich mache es
einfach die spieler ist einfach eine
runde weiter jedenfalls endlich gefallen
ergibt die ja geben einen daumen hoch
darüber will ich mich auf jeden fall
mehr freuen dass es nur ein kleiner
klick das zeigt mir dass es euch
gefallen hat solche folgen jetzt noch
ein eisen raus hat jetzt hier noch zwei
reihen natürlich sagen in der nächsten
folge wenn ihr sehen wollt wie ich
zurückkomme dann schaltet ihr ein auge
dass das pferd das werde ich gleich auch
noch wachsen
ich musste doch zeigen sich vom server
geht los
[Musik]